foreign
after being voted out of office Imran
Khan founded a protest movement he
branded a revolution an out-of-season
re-election campaign now in its eighth
month seemingly indifferent to people
struggling with a broken economy
apparently unflinching in the face of
devastating floods and undeterred even
by attempted assassination
his popularity seems bulletproof but his
critics may be growing in number
Naseem Zakir grew up on these streets
he's been painting signs for local
businesses for decades
he can't hear or speak
but there is no mistaking what he thinks
of the former prime minister
you don't need to understand sign
language to know he is not a fan
Khan started out strong in politics
Naseem says but he's lost his way
there is no shortage of Imran Khan
supporters wherever you go in the
country but in Pakistan's marketplaces
you will find its critics who say that
endless protests and countless rallies
are bad for business
disruption and Chaos in pursuit of
political comeback some Lahori say it
isn't helping anyone but Khan himself
he's like a monkey with a Matchstick
whether he wants to sit someone on fire
or sit the whole jungle on fire it's up
to him the nation is proud of him but as
far as politics go everyone is just
worried about their personal interests
politicians should work together for the
country not just themselves
Imran Khan is a good guy but right now
he's just trying to take advantage of
the situation the country is going
downhill but every politician is worried
about themselves these long marches
these rallies no one is worried about
the people and the cost of living keeps
Rising
for as long as they've had a country
working class pakistanis say they've
been beaten down by divisive Politics
the poor are getting poorer and the mood
on the street is leaders political and
Military don't care
putting themselves or their party before
country
for lahore's business owners the numbers
don't lie the only path to Lasting
political success they say is the
economy
Lahore